[Music]
hey guys welcome back to another video
here on CIPA case this is my very first
solo video that I'm filming in this new
space that we finally got around to
fixing which is our spare office always
kind of been like the storage room it's
like oh one day I'll get to it but
finally it's like no we got to do it you
guys have been asking for videos from me
especially my daily makeup routine from
me for the longest time ever so what is
my daily makeup routine like just I
don't I got to let you guys know right
now don't have high expectations I do
very little and my makeup is just I keep
it really simple I try to go for more of
the natural look but I will show you
what I do with my daily makeup I don't
use a lot of crazy brands just drugstore
stuff keep it simple so let's get
started alright so to get started I
usually use this CC cream by herb or Ian
or Borean the Korean brand they say this
is a high definition radiance face cream
so I get invited to a lot of Beauty
events I want to go to these Beauty
events I'll have these goodie bags with
a lot of products and them for like
influencers to try out and stuff and
this was one of the items that I
received and I love this product so much
I'm not really sure with the whole CC
cream and the BB cream and the I don't
know what else creams but I just know
that this is what I use to start off my
face and I know you're supposed to be
like moisturizing and stuff but I'm just
trying to tell you guys this is what I
do on the daily and I know I'm probably
doing a lot of things wrong but this is
just the way I do it and I wanted to
show you guys since you guys have been
asking me like what do you what do you
do every single day so anyways to start
off I will usually put this on and I'll
just put like little dots across like
all over my face
so I'll start off like this and then
I'll just go down the center and then
I'll make a little circle around around
my cheeks and then just put some on my
forehead and then I just rub it in with
my fingers I really don't have a lot of
fancy tools I don't do any crazy brushes
I literally just use like four brushes
but yeah like I'll just blend it all in
and to my face or on my lips and I'll
bring it down to my neck at least a
little bit and I'll put it around my
eyes so usually I try to cover my dark
circles that's like the number one thing
that bugs me about my face and then I
tried to use makeup for and I've been
recommended a ton of concealers and like
a whole bunch of things to try like and
I'm really bad about being consistent so
I'm pretty sure like the things I've
tried in the past things might have
worked but I'm just not very consistent
with it so I still have dark circles and
I notice I started having dark circles
in the third grade cuz my best friend
pointed it out she was like did you get
in a fight and I'm like no what do you
mean is that cuz guard your eyes it
looks like you have two black eyes and I
looked in the mirror I was like what are
you talking about and she was like yeah
look it's like purple on the bottom I'm
like what is that and then since then
like that just sparked it like in my
mind I'm like forever self-conscious and
my dark circles I would never step foot
outside the house or ever show my face
without at least putting concealer on
like I've always been like super
self-conscious like I grew up with so
many insecurities guys like it's insane
but I still have so many but now I'm
getting close I'm getting better about
not being super insecure just accepting
myself cuz that's what we gotta do right
we just gotta be happy with who we got
so like for example in my ears I've
always been super self-conscious in my
ears cuz the same thing I would think I
was even 11 and I was leaving out of
school I think I was like in the sixth
grade or seventh grade and I was walking
in the field after school and some kid
just runs past me and he's like haha you
have big ears they stick out and he just
left and he just ran away and ever since
then almost like I have Dumbo ears
they're so huge and I used to cover them
up and I would soar like I would rather
be naked than show my ears like that's
how insecure it was about mirrors and
then like years went by and then I told
JK about my insecurities and like Bart
and Jo they'd be like you're crazy and
Gio should just be like oh you have
normal ears like yeah sure they stick
out maybe a little bit but you can't
even tell unless you're pointed out so
then by them telling me and like
you just being like yeah what do I care
so much about my ears like who cares and
so now I just wear them out and I don't
even care anymore
slowly I'm doing that with my dark
circles because even in Hawaii like
whenever we'll go sometimes I'll be like
oh they're too dark and I'll put like
some waterproof concealer and don't go
swimming because I'm just like I'm too
insecure but I'm slowly trying to let
that go
so like for example I started this whole
process with bare face like I I don't
usually show my bare face that much but
anyways moving up first is a CC cream
and then I'll move on to my favorite
favorite thing ever like this concealers
amazing cuz like I said I've tried so
many concealers and I've never found any
that I really love like this one so this
is the Maybelline instant age rewind so
I use a medium and so what I do
just like twist it and then I'll just
dab it on the bottom and then I know
I've seen a lot of like suggestions for
putting on concealer you should do like
a triangle type of thing so I kind of
try to apply it sorta like a triangle or
not really and I'll just do like couple
dabs on the upper lid cuz my upper lids
it's also dark and like somehow like red
a bit and I'll just dab in my finger I
don't use any other brushes I've tried
like the Beauty Blender before and I
just didn't like how you have to wet it
and then I'm just like that's not very
portable and I don't know if they've
come up with different solutions but I
just wasn't a fan of the Beauty Blender
and I also have brushes that I've tried
to apply my concealer and I don't like
how you can see the brushstrokes and
like I said I'm pretty sure I'm doing
things wrong but I've just found that
this is the way that I just like to do
it and it's just quick and simple so
I'll just use my ring finger and I'll
just use it to dab all my concealer just
try to blend it all in
I'll get the corners and I'll make sure
to blend my concealer a lot near the
lash line I remember reading some
comments mentioning that I have like
really smooth eyelids which I think it's
something funny to observe but I think
it's because of my kids
there may be I don't know I really don't
do much but yellow just blend it in and
then sometimes I'll grab some of my
concealer and I'll bring it up top I'm
like the bridge of my nose and then on
the side my my nostrils I'll try to put
some concealer in there do all this and
I try to really really make sure it's
like nice and blended cuz it's happened
to me before like when I first started
learning how to use makeup I think I was
like 14 15 and I would not be good about
blaming my concealer and then I'll take
pictures and just like white patches so
I'm like oh no I gotta really blend it a
little bit better yeah I started
learning how to put on makeup thanks to
my sister sweatin she's she lives in
Mexico she's my half-sister
she taught me just everything I know
about makeup which is everything I still
know about Miko cuz I never really
studied anymore like really tried to
learn like all the new techniques and
the new gadgets and the new stuff I'm
just like I don't know I just stick to
what I know which is knowledge from 10
years ago so this is just what I do this
is bit and then I'll tend to like really
blend right here on the corner on my
upper eyelid because the actual
concealer would start kicking into the
creases and so I'm just trying to blend
it a bit and then once I finish blending
in my concealer I use this sheer
translucent type of powder to like set
my concealer cuz like around my eyes the
skin around my eyes is super super
elastic like it's not really firm and so
because of that I have a lot of wrinkles
and those wrinkles tend to like cake in
the makeup so I i've been using this
recently and i really like it because
it's it like mattifies so just grab a
little bit with this brush and then i'll
just kind of like dab it on top
I don't really blend it or anything I
just kind of DAB it and I'll put it like
on the lid and then I'll just get a
little bit more and then tap it the
excess off and I'll just do that to both
I'll do it to the bottom and to the
upper lid so are you fun like crouching
and where'd I put the mirror under the
camera so hopefully this this is this is
turning out okay oh yeah so after I are
you finished a being this trans
some powder thing then I move on to my
full face powder coverage thing I told
you guys I know nothing of makeup
this is what I use to set everything
else in this is a covergirl outlast all
day in 850 medium to deep so this is
like a matte finishing powder I really
like using covergirl I used to buy a lot
of like the name-brand like super
expensive high-end makeup brands but I
always felt like it's not that big of a
difference from the drugstore so I'm
like why am i spending so much money
when I can just try out different makeup
stuff too because then also when you go
with the high-end stuff it's kind of
hard unless you actually go into like
Sephora or old tea or something and then
you actually try on the makeup but it's
really hard to like really experiment
cuz they're so expensive and then
sometimes I find myself buying a really
expensive product and then I think I
like it in the store and then I'll take
it home and I try using it on the daily
and I'm like I actually don't like it
and I just spent a whole bunch of money
for no reason so I'd rather just take
the risk with drugstore makeup because
at least it's way cheaper and if I don't
like it like oh well it's like just ten
bucks but yeah so then I'll start
putting this on all over my forehead
over my eyes actually use this as well
to like sit in the rest of my concealer
in the translucent powder and I'll put
them on my neck to just really even out
everything make sure my neck matches my
face and honestly guys I'm telling you I
put very little on like I try not to do
that much I don't like how it looks in
the mirror and if it looks cakey in the
mirror like I'm taking makeup off I know
a lot of these makeup trends it's like
cake on the makeup and it looks really
good on camera but then when you
actually see them in person it's like it
you can see like all the lines of the
makeup and I'm like I don't like that so
I need to make sure that I like my
makeup how it looks in the mirror not
just how it looks on camera so that's
why I just do very little like I don't
contour I don't highlight I don't do
anything like I just keep it really
basic for the next I do my blush but I
actually use a bronzer it's so broken
and old and actually use a rubber band
so they keep it closed so yeah I'll
leave it like this this thing is so old
you know who makes this honestly I think
it's fish Physicians Formula shimmer
strips custom bronzer blush eyeshadow
and things it's called Waikiki strip I
don't know it's really like faded it's
really old but anyways so I'll do this
I'll have the lid out and then I'll just
kind of DAB it and then take some off
step it off and then I'll smile and then
just put it on balls of my cheeks and
then I also bring my bronzer up so I'll
put it like right here on my temple so
just kind of like blend it in there just
really lightly I try not to go ham with
this I'll just go up and this is
something that my sister taught me she
was like always put your blush it's
starting from the ball or like new
you're like not exactly on the ball of
your cheek but maybe like a little bit
further back and then bring it up to
your temple I don't know why but I've
been doing it this long and I like how
it looks so I've just been sticking to
it I don't know I really don't know any
other new techniques and then sometimes
if I put a little too much and I feel
like oh I went a little too far then
I'll just go back to my foundation brush
and I'll just put some down here remove
some of the excess make it look a little
lighter not so crazy and it'll take it
off with my hand so then next time I put
on foundation I don't have it like a
bronzy face finish it that wrap my
bronzer back up with my rubber band I
gotta buy a new one I know next I move
on to my eyebrows and then same with
this thing it's really old this is a NYX
eyebrow cake powder thing brunette I
don't know
so my eyebrows are really funky I have a
cowlick right here on my left eyebrow
like in the center this is why I tend to
put put most of my eyebrow what is this
powder
yeah eyebrow powder and that's cuz like
right here with this cowlick thing it
tends to grow a lot lighter so then if I
don't put anything it looks like I don't
have eyebrows so I have to fill it in
here
I bought this specific thing because it
had like eyebrow gel and so I thought I
would like keep my eyebrows in place so
I have a calendar problem with my left
eyebrow
with my right eyebrow right near where
it arches it always tends to go down
like this so then I bought this eyebrow
gel hoping it would work but it just
ended up being like Vaseline and you
just like makes my hairs like stick
together but it's still dropped so it
doesn't it didn't really work for me so
I don't even use it anymore throughout
the day I'm constantly like pushing my
hair back up cuz it always falls I don't
know why maybe you guys have a different
solution but I did not like this eyebrow
gel thing that NYX has maybe there's
another product out there you guys can
help a girl out I'll go in with this
like angled kind of brush which I taped
because I like this brush and I want to
buy a new one so I just taped it cuz
this top kept falling out I'm telling
you guys my makeup is so old I gotta buy
new stuff but it works it's fine anyways
so then I'll start filling it in again
I'll go of really lightly I don't try
going crazy with my eyebrows either I'll
fill in the top here cuz that tends to
look really light and looks like I have
really thin eyebrows and then I'll try
using this brush to create an angle so I
kind of like it when it looks a little
bit like pointy in the arch but then
here I tend to like really try to fill
this in because it's like bulbs it's
really weird and then use hairs too they
go like straight up and then these hairs
they they're their team they know what
to do they know that they should go this
way but then the left hairs are like
nope we're going straight up so every
time I go get my eyebrows done I always
have to tell the lady like because
sometimes I've got a wax sometimes I'm
gonna thread it but I tell her to be
careful with the left eyebrow cuz
especially right here in the center it's
deceiving but usually they do a really
good job the gallic go into the the
right eyebrow next I always start with
the left one because of that bald spot
and I'll go to the right and I'll try
like brushing all my eyebrow hairs up so
at least in the meantime you can stay up
but then as soon as I move my err
because I tend to be really expressive
with my face and I'll move my eyebrows
and I'll go like this and then the hairs
will just go back down well just for now
I'll just try brushing it
and then creating the point of my arch I
like doing that and then I'll bring it
down and I'll create like the little
tail end of my eyebrows so I'll kind of
go like that same with the side little
tail end and that's all I'm doing my
rows and then I move on to eyeliner
lately I've been kind of getting lazy
and I just skipped this eyeliner part
and I'll just go on to do my eyelashes
and call it a day but now I'll just show
you guys how I do my eyeliner I'll get
another mirror so I could get closer and
then oh so for the eyeliner I use
L'Oreal linear intense this is black so
I've always I tried different liquid
eyeliners and I've always find myself
going back to L'Oreal because I really
like how I just like the brush it's not
too thin it's not too thick and I like
how it moves and I'm able to control it
so I really like the L'Oreal eyeliner
I'll start like in the center my way out
to the end and then I'll go back into
the inner corner and I'll meet the
center and then sometimes I go too thin
so I've got to go over it again and
sometimes like this eyeliner um if you
ever experienced it when you're putting
on your liquid eyeliner for some reason
the brush take the makeup with you know
you're like wait no I need to fill it in
so then I'll just end up just dabbing
like the edge the edges of the brush and
then I'll give me more makeup more
pigmentation so that's sometimes what I
do especially near the inner corner
that's when it tends to happen to me if
I don't do the same on the side in high
school I used to always do the winged
eyeliner and then for some reason just
out of high school I kind of lost my
touch and I can never do a winged liner
ever again and I've tried like
throughout these years I've actually
tried to do it and I'm like I lost my
touch I can do it and I've even seen
like hacks where people will create like
stamps I saw this one hack where this
girl she cut the edge of a pink eraser
into like a triangle and she used that
for a snap and it looked really good so
I'm like oh I should try that I just
haven't gotten around to do it oh I
think I made a gun way too big thick on
this one
don't do it too thick I think I did I
had to go over it this other one to
match it and then I try to bring the
eyeliner to my corner because I tend to
notice that I don't really get a lot of
my corners so I'm really weird and I
actually plug all my eyelashes and I
know I'm gonna get a lot of heat for
this but I do I pluck out my eyelashes
if they're straight cuz I I have
naturally curly eyelashes and so if
they're if they just end up growing
straight then I just pluck it out like I
don't want to deal with you and I don't
even own an eyelash curler so I just
pluck them out and usually the top
eyelashes on the outer corners those are
the ones that end up growing out
straight so I just end up just plucking
them out so if you look really closely
in my outer corner of my eyes it's kind
of bald cuz I flipped those eyelashes
out I know I'm weird I know I'm weird
I've heard it my whole life because even
when I was younger I used to get really
killed even more by my friends because I
was so weird that my eyelashes they
would grow so long that it would tickle
my eyebrows so I would trim them and my
friends did one time they saw me because
I had my little trimming scissors and I
was just trimming it and then they were
like what are you doing and I'm like oh
that's cuz they tickle my eyebrows I
always trim them and they're like what
you're crazy
do you know look at you are you know how
many girls wish they had those eyelashes
and I'm like I know but they bother me
sorry like I just feel so weird every
time I talk about my eyelashes a lot of
people can't relate to me but anyways
moving on to mascara so when it comes to
mascara I experiment a lot I like trying
all different kinds of mascara every
single time I buy a mascara I tend to
buy a different one but lately I've been
using this one this is the covergirl
total tease this has actually been one
of my favorite mascaras recently cuz I
really like the brush it has bristles
only on one side and then on the other
side only on the tip does they have
bristles and not the rest of the brush
so I don't know you guys can see that
I like this mascara brush it's been
really helpful and keeping my eyelash
just like straight and in order cuz it
as soon as they start getting tangled up
I get so frustrated I know I said I'm
weird I know that I'm weird but yeah so
that's why I like this brush cuz it just
like comes it really straight so you all
start off with at the base and I just
do a little wiggle and then bring it up
I remember in high school I had a friend
that she saw me put on my mascara and
she was so blown away based off of the
fact that I don't need to open my mouth
cuz I guess a lot of girls when they put
mascara on me go yes
and I never did that I don't know I just
never learned to do that and I feel like
I my eyes are just big enough already I
don't really need to open my mouth to
make them even bigger I don't know I I
guess that I remember her telling me
like girl that's a talent you could put
your mascara on with your mouth closed
that's a talent I'm like okay I guess I
found her you talent I don't know she
was kidding though it's pretty funny
imagine yeah my talent is to put on
mascara with my mouth closed that's my
job I'll be funny but yeah so I'll just
use the end that has all of the bristles
and then once I end up applying the
mascara on my lashes and I'll go back in
with the other end that only has it as a
tip with the bristles at the tip and
then I'll go in there and I'll kind of
just brush them so like strain out a
little bit more I'll use that and as
well the one that only has the tip the
brush bristles on the tip for my bottom
lashes I'll just lightly put mascara on
I try not to go too crazy with the
bottom lashes I remember hearing a roll
like you should never put mascara on
your bottom lashes but oh no I do it I
don't even know if that rule is still
relevant because I haven't been keeping
up with makeup trends or anything like
that there's all stuff that I learned
from my sister ten years ago so I know
I'm out of date all right so we're done
with mascara so this is something that I
used to do I haven't been doing it that
often eight anymore but I'll just do it
for this video cuz I just want to show
you guys how I did it but I would grab
this brush and then I have this like
highlighting powder in this bag that
I've had for a long time I don't know
just highlighter a powder expired maybe
I should get rid of this this powder it
broke so I put in this little baggie
and I'll just get this brush and I'll
just scrape the edge of the bag I'll
just get a little bit of the
highlighting powder just like tap some
off and then I'll go into my inner
corners and I'll put some in there and
then also put it on arches and my brows
so I'll put some like right where it
starts to curve just to make it stand
out a little bit yeah I haven't done
this in a while it kind of got lazy and
then I'll put a little bit on the outer
corner that's it that's all I do
once I finish with all that I go into
putting some eyeliner on my waterline so
this is a Maybelline master Kajal I
think that's how you pronounce it this
is midnight brown I really like these
like fat eyeliner pencils because it's
not super pigmented where it's like oh
you have to be careful how you put it
you could just kind of like smudge it on
and it will kind of like smudge it for
this I don't like it when it's too clean
so usually what I do is like I'll put
them on and then I'll wait a few minutes
then go do something else and I'll come
back and I'll put some more and then
I'll give it like that shadowy effect
like the smoky eye kind of thing and
I'll put it on the top like so yeah my
eyes are not sensitive to things
touching it like my eyeballs cuz I wore
contact since I was 11 and like I was
really dirty with my contacts too so
just like go in there grab it take it
out and then just put on another one and
so like my eyes are really used to
things touching it like makeup and
contacts and stuff so whenever I put my
eyeliner on I don't have to do this and
like go like that I could just put it on
directly so then once I finished the top
one then I'll go into the corners like I
said I'm bald on the outer corners of my
eyes so I'll just go in there I'll just
like fill it in a bit so I don't look
too weird then I finish it off with I
put some just regular old chapstick
I'll put chapstick on my lips this one
though I bought this one in France it's
so good I really like this brand I
should look for it here because I want
to buy me one of these I already ran out
of my chapstick it's like almost all
gone but this is the ivenna brand and
this actual chapstick thingy it's called
cold cream so I don't know I've been
using it I love it I'm running out I
needed my new one I'll put this on first
before my lipstick just take sure like
my lips are moisturize at least I'm good
about my lips about moisturizing I'm bad
about my face moisturizing but my lips
are moisturize honestly I've been trying
to look for a moisturizer to put on
before I do my makeup then every time I
try looking into it I'm like oh there's
so many options I get so overwhelmed so
I'm like I'm good with my CC cream like
I'm just gonna stick to that anyway so
then I'll put this lipstick and this is
like the lipstick that I wear like
almost all the time now and this is by
Revlon and it's the ceci mauve for 63
the number of the lipstick and I love
this color I love like it's not too loud
but it's not too subtle like it's pretty
good so I really like it I'll just put
that on
and then that's it and I don't put
eyeshadow I really rarely put on
eyeshadow it's like usually if I go to
an event or something then maybe I'll
put eyeshadow on but this is generally
all I do and then I set it all with this
DL supreme glow mist and it's like this
really cool like setting spray that
gives you a facial glow and I have been
seeing a lot of comments saying that I
just look like I'm glowing thank you for
that but I will like to give credit to
this spray and the fact that I'm a very
happy newlywed you know the newlywed
glow I think I have maybe I don't know
but this braid it does wonders it smells
really good so I'm running out I
actually need more this product was one
of those products that I mentioned
earlier that I get when I go to the
events like beauty events I went to VL
Beauty event I was even live-streaming
there so if you guys saw me like
streaming and I was in this like huge
mansion thing they had this really cool
party know the launch party for this
brand but I need to hit them up I need
to get a new one cuz I love this mist
it's so cool so I set my whole makeup
with this I'm just like sprayed on a few
times and then I'll just let it dry on
my face and since I'm running out of
this I only use it when I film now so
I'll set my face whenever I'm filming
nothing that's how I do my daily makeup
every single day this is my routine and
it's super simple I don't use anything
expensive crazy or I guess this would be
pretty expensive I think this is pricey
other than that I don't like spending
money on makeup I am really cheap when
it comes to makeup and clothes I just
try to find the cheapest thing but yeah
I mean if you guys see any part in my
routine where you're like oh she could
probably benefit from this tip then
please let me know I'll be reading your
comments and I'll be trying to do more
of these beauty videos that I've
promised you guys like a year ago or
maybe longer I think I promised you guys
a long time ago but I'll be trying to do
my best to do more of these videos maybe
show you guys some of my outfits cuz I
know a lot of you guys have been asking
for videos like what are we where maybe
you guys have some other video ideas you
can let me know in the comments and I'll
do my best to work on them and make them
for you so you can get a little insight
into my brain this is what my brain
thinks but let me know what you guys
think thanks for watching
[Music]